today I'll stick to football old boy do
we have a big show for you - a tongue of
our lowest decision is in the Dallas
Cowboys have a head coach Tom Brady is a
free agent
so drew Brees by the way Connor we have
a huge show today and we had already
planned to fix the Cowboys now we're
gonna fix them knowing who the head
coaches and of course we're gonna answer
your guys draft on draft questions but
this is one of the more loaded stick to
football subs we've had I feel like last
week they were all like an hour and a
half long but to his decision Jalen
hurts to the Senior Bowl there's just so
much going on right now but we're gonna
definitely start by looking back at what
just happened in the NFL yeah I mean
there's so much news coming in at once
whether it's teams looking for their
future whether it seems playing further
now and obviously this was a gigantic
weekend in the NFL with the playoffs
with the opening round some gigantic
losses here Matt I mean a lot of people
probably picked the Saints and the
Patriots to be playing in the Super Bowl
and they don't even win one playoff game
I think when you look at teams like the
Titans obviously this is really exciting
for them I'm sure Bills fans are really
upset but they have a promising future
there and I think it's good for us just
we talk about the bad teams all the time
on the show but we never talk about the
teams that are just trying to get over
the hump or the teams that are playing
really well and it's kind of a State of
the Union for us for where does some of
these teams go do they start rebuilding
or are they just getting things going in
the right direction now yeah it is
it's fascinating like I said we we do
spend so much time talking about the
Browns you know we talk about the
Dolphins the bengals but we don't spend
a lot of time with New England New
Orleans I mean even teams like Buffalo
that's up-and-coming you'll - a little
bit of a Josh Allen meltdown late in the
fourth quarter we might be talking about
them it's a completely different team
right now the Eagles just can't seem to
stay healthy so there's there's a lot
going on I think where we start and I'll
be transparent we are so we record
Monday morning like always we're waiting
for - his decision to come in so segment
2 is gonna be all two today so just wait
wait for the head I know if you're
listening you're like why are they
burying the lead on this it's a timing
thing so we're gonna start with
NFL Mike McCarthy Connor doesn't move
the needle for you because for me it was
like yeah that's the best that you can
do and I'll say this I don't know that
the end of what happened in Green Bay
was all Mike McCarthy's fault
I feel like Ted Thompson had grown
complacent to some degree and and Ted is
an older guy who's having some health
problems not like he was just lazy so I
feel like that that was just we said on
time like that situation got a little
stale from the front office and from the
head coach and they completely clean
house really when when Brian took over
is the GM there they bring in Matt
Lafleur they're at number two seed in
the NFC right now we'll see what they do
this coming weekend but it feels like a
lot of people what to look at the end of
might McCarthy's right at Green Bay an
only point to finger at him only blame
him for the struggles that this team had
I think that's not fair I know we say
it's still like how is Aaron Rodgers
only good receiver Davante Adams how did
they not invest you know earlier in the
running back position like now they have
Aaron Jones they look really good they
have Jamal Williams looks really good
but it does feel like the front office
for the longest time kind of did what
New England is done right now it's like
we have Aaron Rodgers we don't need to
invest early picks in wide receivers or
tight ends we're gonna try to build
defense and let Aaron be Aaron and he'll
go out there and make crazy plays and
we're gonna win games and I think when
Mike McCarthy you know get he shares
some blame of this his clock management
has never been good but it I do think
the front office deserves at least a
share in some of the criticism for how
things ended there I think so too I
don't think this team that Matt Lafleur
inherited is the same one that McCarthy
lost with I think that's something
that's really important to note here I
mean guti went out and added a lot of
free agent additions on this defense
this team it was really built on their
defense and their rushing attack now
Lafleur deserves credit for that there's
no doubt about it but it's not like he
took McCarthy's team and got however
many more wins out of them that's not
what we're saying here now when you
start this segment Matt and asked me
does this higher move the needle for me
no it doesn't I don't think it's a bad
hire that doesn't mean I think it's a
good one
it seems so average right now it's like
they didn't get very far away from what
they already had in Jason Garrett now I
think Mike McCarthy is an upgrade I want
to make that clear I think that it was
time to move on from Jason Garrett I
think Mike McCarthy can be good for Zach
Prescott I think another thing that
we're gonna find out very soon what this
is it seems like Jerry Jones wants to
keep a lot of members of that offensive
staff and maybe Mike McCarthy is open to
working with them open to mentoring them
we've seen this in the past before with
Dallas sometimes they like guys on their
staff and they like mentoring them and
working them up the ranks in Dallas
maybe that's Jon Kitna maybe that's
Kellen Moore gonna be really interesting
to see how young guys like that you know
grow there I think when I look at this
higher douses roster is good enough to
be in the Super Bowl this year and they
didn't make the playoffs Mike McCarthy
is good enough to get you there he's
shown that before but he has to make
some changes Matt he has to put you know
put his money where his mouth is we need
to see a more analytically driven head
coach we need to see a guy that improves
decision-making in games we need to see
a guy that grows with the league so when
I look at McCarthy I think the year off
was good for him I want to say that
because I had talked to some teams you
know that were that got to speak with
him or had asked people around him that
and you know whether they opted to
interview him or not and they felt like
he was just a little burnt out of how
things ended in Green Bay the energy the
passion the foot on the gas mentality
wasn't fully there and maybe that year
off builds it back up and brings it back
and bring something good to Dallas yeah
I think that that is good for him and it
it's easy to just point the finger and
say it was Mike McCarthy's fault but
again the roster that he's getting in
Dallas is much better than what he had
in Green Bay there's already been rumors
that he's going to bring in Mike Nolan
as his defensive coordinator Mike is
right now the linebackers coach with the
New Orleans Saints and has a phenomenal
history in the NFL as a defensive
coordinator so I like that hire I do
wonder what happens to Kellan more what
happens to Chris Rashard is interviewing
for jobs if they bring in Mike Nolan
obviously he could stay as the defensive
passing game coordinator but
that might be unlikely if he were able
to leave and get promotion so I am very
excited to see what Mike does with the
staff because I think one thing were
being sold here is that he has changed
and I don't know if I buy that when all
you do is bring back the guys that
you've worked with in the past so I like
I would like to see them shake things up
now moving on we have three jobs that
are still open the Cleveland Browns a
job that Mike McCarthy did not want to
interview for the Carolina Panthers and
the New York Giants now the New York
Giants will be interviewing Joe Jacobs
today Monday he's the patriot special
teams coordinator
they'll be interviewing Matt rule
tomorrow Tuesday it feels like this is
probably Matt rules job if he wants it
Conor Cleveland whether it's Kevin
Stefanski or Josh McDaniels those are
the two guys that when you talk to
people around the league they kind of
feel like those are the favorites I'll
be honest with Carolina I have not heard
any rumblings about who a favorite might
be but they are interviewing you know
all the all the people whose names
you've heard you know whether it's Matt
rule or Josh McDaniels or Robert Salah
it feels like the Panthers are doing
their due-diligence yeah they are I mean
they're a team that spoke to Mike
McCarthy before the regular season had
even ended which I think was a smart
move for them if you're a new owner you
want to gauge what you're looking for
and I like that Tepper didn't go into
this and say hey I had Ron Rivera it's
time for me to go the complete other way
he went into this saying I'm gonna talk
to a lot of different people now what I
will say is you bring up Matt rule if
Carolina loves Matt rule while we're
recording this show Matt because he's
interviewing there today you don't let
him leave
because if you let Emily stay the night
like Jerry Jones did in my car you do
this slumber party special is what you
do you make the pizza rolls you do
whatever you got to do and keep them in
the building at listen I think Matt rule
this situation is going to be very
interesting because number one yes I
like what he hears from either of these
teams let's not forget he turned down
the Browns he's speaking to both the
Panthers and the Giants he just go back
to Baylor make a nice salary when a lot
of football games in the big 12
interview for NFL jobs next year if he
likes those better what I will say is it
does feel like this is the year where
he's going to take one of those
I know he's come out and said he expects
to be back at Baylor next year s coach
speak never buy into that but I'll say
this if Carolina really wants the guy
they can't let him leave because I think
the Giants if they're smart are gonna
open up the checkbook and make them
their next coach and I'll tell you I'm
talking to people in the big 12 this I
didn't believe this when I first had
this conversation so I was like oh come
on there are people in the big 12 that
won in Matt rule to leave more than they
want Lincoln Riley to leave like they
were very worried about what Matt rule
can build at Baylor because he's such a
good coach like obviously Oklahoma Texas
are always gonna out recruit Baylor but
Matt rule in the big 12 beliefs the
belief is that he's a better coach than
Tom Herman he's a better coach than
Lincoln Riley I mean Lincoln's great on
offense but what Matt rule is building
there's a program there are people in
the big 12 that are like going to
breathe a huge sigh of relief if and
when Matt rule takes a job like you said
that might be today I think you can look
back at the college coaches who have
failed and say like well it doesn't
really work I think Matt is different
because of his time spent in the NFL and
like you said it feels like he has had
his eye on that Giants job since he
basically had the Jets job last year you
know it was like okay well I'm gonna go
home and I think there is even though
we've seen these teams finally execute a
trade I do think and you know this
better than me there is a rivalry there
where I think Matt rule does want to go
to New York and go to the Giants to be
successful and kind of you know bite its
thumb a little bit at the New York Jets
and say you could have had this like
this could be me right now but instead
you have old googly eyes calling the
plays so I think that that's an element
of it yeah I mean it's always great to
go home again to get back to where you
know you had kind of your coaching start
so I I feel like the Giants job is the
one that he has eyes for but you're
right if David Tepper wants to say
here's eight million dollars a year or
whatever it's gonna take for you to
leave Baylor it's probably not that much
there's seven million dollars a year we
want you to come build a program and you
get to start with a clean slate because
everyone's gone except for Marty her
knee and that feels like a temporary
abode for the front office too you know
they've said they're gonna bring in new
people mat rule didn't take the jets job
because they wanted to have some control
over his staff the Panthers can offer
this man a clean
whiteboard and say build the football
program that you want will pay for it
here you go
listen if I'm the Panthers I'm getting
it done I don't care I'm not letting you
leave I'm not letting you go up to the
New York Giants I'm gonna do everything
I can to keep you there I think and I've
had an interesting question come up
about Matt rule a couple times over this
last week and they said well what you
know what is he good at and a lot of
people like to use the word I use this
all the time program builder a guy that
could take something from scratch and
mold it into a winning team in college
football that's that 10 win mark
something he's gotten to a temple
something he's gotten to at Baylor but
let's get it right here Matt he's been a
coach at pretty much every single
position who's been an offensive
coordinator at temple he's been a
quarterbacks coach at temple he's been a
defensive line coach over there he's
been an assistant offensive line coach
with the Giants he's been head coaches
of multiple college programs and built
them up this is somebody that's coming
in and he knows where to put the pieces
of the puzzle and I think that's the
most important quality to have in
today's NFL you see all these guys like
I hate to ring the Jets example all the
time but the Jets hired a guy that he
lives and dies with the quarterback he
doesn't talk to the defense and listen
sometimes that works a lot of people
said think Sean McVeigh's like that Sean
McVeigh has a relationship with the
entire team you need guys same with Kyle
Shanahan Shanahan has a relationship
with the entire team but you need head
coaches that can put their assistance in
the right spots their players in the
right spots with those assistants and I
think that's what makes Matt rule so
good as job I mean you can look Matt
rule has been a head coach since 2015 he
has 16 players in the NFL from Temple
and Baylor that's not like he was
coaching at LSU no not all those guys
were drafted but 16 players in the NFL
tells you a lot about the respect that
general managers have for what he's
doing there and and to your point Conor
people do say that I like well what does
he coach we coaches football number one
and when you're in the NFL as a head
coach it's not like you're you know
you're not coaching quarterbacks every
day or you probably shouldn't be if you
are but Matt rule has I think his best
attribute if we're gonna talk about
being a hands on position coach it is
going to be more of that offensive line
tight end but he has experienced his
quarterbacks coach as a run game
coordinator he could do a little bit of
everything with the
she was an assistant online coach so I
think with him it's more like you said
he's a program builder but he also does
have experience with position groups and
to be the you know big 12 coach of the
year this past year two-term Baylor from
where Art Briles left Baylor to where
they are now there were 1 and 11 yep
they won what 11 games this year they
would have won this year and so I think
when Matt rule it's just that ability to
come in and look at things and say this
is what we need to do to turn this
around and I have to wonder if his guy
Robbie Anderson oh you had a temple if
they wherever Matt goes I feel like you
can just go ahead and slot Robbie
there's a free agent
I think Carolina would be interesting we
know they have a lot of speed with
Christian McCaffrey and DJ more I think
the Giants would be interesting because
you know they have a good plan they
found in darius Slayton golden Tate's
there even though he's getting a little
older I'm with you I think that if you
know they're very very close to this day
Robbie often has credited Matt rule and
his family for helping him a lot and get
his career on track so I think that is a
very interesting small nuggets keep an
eye on to see wherever he goes one last
thing and getting away from the coaching
cycle which I'm very interested to
follow him and should to see if josh
mcdaniels really does leave and the
reason I bring up josh mcdaniels is matt
we got to talk about these New England
Patriots I think they have one of the
most interesting off seasons out of any
team in the National Football League
right now approaching us yeah they do
and you know it starts with Tom Brady
who for the first time in his 20-year
career is a free agent the franchise tag
cannot be applied to him and watching
the postgame after their loss their home
loss to Tennessee Titans it felt like
any Brady said you know it's unlikely
I'm gonna retire and Bill Belichick said
you know we have to have communication
on all sides Robert Kraft in a great
interview with Peter King said you know
they want Tom back they want to make it
work they're hoping that he either comes
back or retires well Tom says he's
probably not retiring so I think first
and foremost Robert Kraft if it's up to
him Tom Brady will remain in England
Patriot as long as I've had a platform
to talk about football I've been telling
you guys this there's a reason that
Jimmy Garoppolo is not the quarterback
the New England Patriots right now with
Tom Brady to pay the quarter back to the
San Francisco 49ers that's because
Robert Kraft not Bill Belichick so we're
going to see a little bit here I don't
wanna call it a power struggle but we're
gonna see a little bit of who does call
the shots here because of its Bob Kraft
Brady will be back in Vince Bill
Belichick I don't know if he will be and
there are a lot of interesting
destinations that we can throw out there
and I think first though is do the
Patriots move on from Brady can they
honestly move on for Brady Jarrett
Stidham is the backup they are not gonna
have enough draft picks and we'll wait
to see what the penalties are for
filming the Cincinnati Bengals they're
not gonna have enough draft picks to go
get Joe burrow they're not gonna have
enough draft picks to go get Justin
Herbert so do they like Jordan love do
they like Jacob Eason do they feel like
maybe there's a chance to a false doing
a Patriots are gonna be drafting at
number 23 overall which is honestly the
earliest I can remember their original
draft pick being in the first round in
the ten years have been doing this so I
think that that is first question can
they even replace this guy or do they
like Jairus did him enough so they can
move on with him I know our guy Melo
loved Jarret Stidham
I thought Jarrett's junior year at
Auburn he looked really really good then
he lost basically everyone in his senior
he struggled he had a great senior Bowl
he had a good combine and in very very
small sample sizes this year I thought
he looked ok but that's not enough to
evaluate on yeah I think when you look
at Siddim I think he you know is a guy
you can live with as a backup I don't
think he's a guy that you're building
your franchise around going forward and
I think that makes this situation more
interesting for New England because
there's so many variables here Matt if
they want to bring back Brady how much
longer does Bill and I'm not saying I
feel one way or the other I don't know
but how much longer does Bill want to
keep that ship going do they feel they
could bring back Brady on a two-year
deal and get enough pieces this
offseason to complement where his level
of play is at because there weren't a
ton of pieces around him this year but
at the end of the day you have to be
honest with yourself and say he did
decline it happens to everyone and Brady
you can only be you know a superhero for
so long before you need a lot of people
to elevate you and I
Brady realizes that I think he's been
open and honest and knows that this team
needs to get a lot better now the big
thing here is they traded a second-round
pick for Mohamed Sanu not a good trade
nothing not a good trade what a great
trade for the Atlanta Falcons in awful
trade for the New England Patriots and
when you look at what Emanuel Sanders
has done in San Francisco for what
seemed like less draft capital it makes
you kind of scratch your head so I think
when you look at their future at
quarterback well the one thing I'll tell
you New England should not do if Tom
Brady moves on or New England moves on
they mutually you know part ways I don't
think New England should panic this
offseason and take the best quarterback
on the board when they pick I don't
think that's what you do I think you sit
there and you say you know what we're
gonna keep building this roster maybe we
trade it for a quarterback there's gonna
be some interesting ones on the trade
market this year I'm not saying Cam
Newton in New England but I'm just
saying there's gonna be interesting
corner baggage and if Brady decides to
leave the market to be the next
quarterback the New England Patriots
like if you're Teddy Bridgewater that's
how you're interesting you do whatever
it takes to get me that job that's the
interesting one to me is Teddy over
there with New England so you know if
the panic and draft someone you can find
an option while you kick that can down
the road define your future I think the
biggest variable for me is does Bill
just want a coach forever and does he
want a coach in New England forever
right yeah that is that I don't know on
the flip side let's just speculate if
Brady were to leave and this is
something Melo and I were talking about
all weekend if Brady were to leave where
does he even go because obviously if
you're leaving you want to leave for a
better situation than you have now
and we can look at the teams that
actually need quarterbacks okay the
bengals are gonna draft Joe burrow
they're not gonna they're not assign 42
year-old Tom Brady the Miami Dolphins
you want to get back with Brian Flores
they have no offensive line so I think
that's a concern the Los Angeles
chargers guess or the Chargers no
offensive line I mean I could see LA
working but like that almost feels like
a slap in the face you're gonna make Tom
Brady go playing a soccer stadium it's a
little weird
right Carolina but it's it's so good for
the Chargers it's good for the NFL as
well if it happens because you can't
sell tickets there to the home team but
Tom Brady would allow you to do that so
I'm sure that if he's going to leave the
NFL wants him to go to the Chargers
I personally what I know about Brady I
can't see him pulling a Johnny Unitas
and ending his career with the Chargers
you know and this awful team we're not
awful team excuse me but this awful
situation where they're in the middle of
a move and like the city doesn't even
really want them and it's just it feels
so messy that Brady would I feel like he
would almost beg I deserve better than
this I'm not here so we're in a soccer
stadium here's a wild one for you that I
just want to happen I want him to go to
the Raiders I do too that's what I okay
that's what I was gonna say you have a
good offensive line you have a head
coach that has a lot of respect around
the league you have a very very good
general manager Mike man that's gonna
get better you got two first-round picks
you got all-pro right tackle I I think
it makes sense I think the Raiders do
now they do have Derek Carr so there's
that part of it but Tom Brady in Las
Vegas is like what we actually need as
football fans is him quarterbacking the
Death Star and it would be the biggest
he'll turn ever like oh the Patriots
won't build a team for me I'm gonna go
back to the team that started it all
with the Tuck rule game so there's a
little bit of poetry in that if I'm
gonna go back to the Raiders to the most
hated team in the NFL and to stay in the
AFC to have a chance to play the
Patriots again that feels like the end
of the Tom Brady movie that I want to
watch it'd be incredible it would be so
fun and like you made a great point
about the Raiders they have draft
capital to keep getting better and I
know a lot of Raiders fans you know they
go hey our defense was not very good to
see you you can't put it on car I get it
we're not we're not kicking their car to
the side we're just we're saying how fun
would it be with Jon Gruden Tom Brady
the Raiders who are ascending right now
I know this season didn't end the way
they wanted it to but once again you
have draft capital you have some cap
space you have some young players that
are continuing to get better this is the
storyline that the
fell needs it absolutely is so we'll be
tracking it to see where Tom Brady ends
up what Drew Brees is also for agent he
let it be known he wants to go back to
New Orleans his regular season prey play
seems like they would want him back last
couple post seasons I don't know I don't
know if they did or not Phillip Rivers
also a free agent so a lot of teams that
for years counter we felt like as a
playoff team they have Drew Brees dev
Tom Brady that Phillip Rivers they're
locked in we're gonna see a lot of
changes at quarterback for for many many
teams this upcoming offseason and let's
take a break when we come back it is to
a time the decision has been made to a
chunk of I Lowell will get into it right
after this to a tongue of Aloha is in
the 2020 NFL Draft will now feature one
of the most popular college football
players that I can remember and also
unfortunately one of the most injured
players that I can remember and I think
Connor we have to go back to freshman to
a coming off the bench or replacing
Jalen hurts and leading Alabama to a
national championship what we saw in his
sophomore season where he really
developed it became in my opinion the
best quarterback in college football
last year with his touch his timing his
accuracy his ability to extend the play
and then this year unfortunately marred
by injury with the ankle within the hip
fracture there's a lot that we don't
know about where to a tongue of Eylau
will go from here the combine checks in
late February are gonna be huge and the
combine read checks in early April will
be even bigger
I cannot remember a player other than
Jaylon Smith where the medicals will be
more important than the film review
because the film review with tua is
special he might be the best quarterback
in this class if we didn't have to think
about the ankle in the hip but we do
have to think about them and I think
there would be a huge part of the
evaluation process right now I have 2a
ranked as the number 2 quarterback in
this draft class the number a 7 overall
player on my big board he's a special
guy the toughness is there the
leadership's there we've heard coach
Nick Saban talk about the intangibles
that he brings to this team in the
locker room in the classroom on the
field a special player I'm excited that
he has entered the 20/20 class my hope
is that this means the doctor's
appointment he had last week was
positive
they feel like he's gonna be able to get
back on the field sooner rather than
later that listen I think number one I
did believe this was the best decision
for him right now it go get paid go get
drafted stop you know risking your body
for free it was time to do this for two
and I'm really excited that he's in the
strafes I'm really optimistic for the
future of his health and I think listen
Matt I've said it many times on this
show he is the most talented quarterback
in this draft he really is and I know
people are gonna sit there and gasp and
say how can you say that after the
season geo borough had listened Jo
burrows older than - I - it didn't have
the time that Joe burrow had and I think
of course I have Joe burrow ranked
higher health is such a factor it is in
doing this entire process but when
people turn on the film and they see all
the little things that Tia does whether
it's elite ball placement all three
levels of the fields it's the
maneuverability and the elusiveness in
the pocket and hopefully those things
still exist after this long rehab that's
another question another piece of this
puzzle but - it could play and you don't
have to sit here and make this an
either/or between Joe burrow or - right
you can sit here and recognize that this
draft class now has two very very good
quarterback prospects it really does and
again we're we're gonna talk about - a
lot over the next three months and we're
talking a lot about what we see on the
field with him because we don't know
about the medicals and barring
information coming out it's unlikely
that we will and it's gonna make him an
intriguing case study with the draft now
I will say this there's been a lot of
talk back and forth between Scouts and
agents about what should he do should he
go back to Alabama where they have
really world-class rehab facilities
they're gonna take care of - that was
never a concern but I think one argument
I heard was that why not go to the NFL
where they are invested in getting you
right not just for one year they're
invested in getting you right for five
years ten years and so I think what -
it's that it had to weigh into this
decision of okay I'm gonna go probably
be the number five Number six number
seven picking the draft and whether it's
the Dolphins
you probably hope it's not the Chargers
given their their history with injured
players or the Panthers
you're gonna go somewhere where they're
gonna make sure that you're right you
can get on the field with - I got hurt
we really heard there was a six-month
window and that window is basically the
NFL Draft the end of April so I think
those medical rejects like I said in
early April will be huge this could be a
situation where you know like the Dallas
Cowboys they had intimate knowledge of
Jalen Smith's new injury and the
prognosis because their doctor did his
surgery they knew where he was at and so
they felt comfortable selecting him at
the top around - I don't think anyway
Toole falls that far in the draft I
still think Connor he's a top-10 pick
unless there's a major change in terms
of his what we know about his injury and
when he'll be able to get on the field
where that is out I mean you said you
haven't met seven I haven't met seven
that hasn't changed since our big board
show and I'll be very transparent with
this as medical news comes in and
hopefully it becomes more and more
positive - it will move up my board it's
as simple as that exactly yes I think he
will be a top five player in this class
I'm optimistic in in modern health
getting him right and keeping him
hopefully keeping him healthy the NFL
has we learned and while we've learned
for many years now Matt and we've seen
it with Carson Wentz and hopefully he'll
be okay for the long term we saw with
Andrew Luck II retired it is hard to
stay healthy at any position in the NFL
yeah and I think for to it that's gonna
be something that has to be taken very
seriously but I'm optimistic in him
coming back I'm excited for this I'm
excited to watch even more film I feel
like we've seen it all a million times
because we've watched and played for a
long time we've been excited about him
being such a promising NFL player and I
think once again this is just one of
those things that it's great for the
draft this shakes up the entire draft we
know Joe Broz going one we know chase
young is going to as something you
always say this draft starts at number
three right and what's gonna happen is
somebody gonna move up and trade for two
is somebody gonna try to jump the
Dolphins are the Giants picking at for
gonna be in a spot where they can
finally get more trade assets we'll Dave
gentlemen ever do that the storylines in
this draft with to a part of it are
officially endless and I think that is
something that I've had been asked about
do the Redskins consider taking calls
and I will say this I think that would
be one of the dumbest things they've
ever done and Canton could be a cold
take I could be this could be on Twitter
in three years that I said this but you
have to take chase Young at number two
overall so the ripple effect of two
entering it doesn't in my opinion affect
pick number one which will be Joe burrow
or pick number two which will be chase
young now at three if I'm the Detroit
Lions you start putting it out right now
that you're interested in trading out
and I know that's early but that does
not matter to me we saw the New York
Jets trade up to number three overall in
March I think you put out right now that
hey we would be okay moving back and you
got to wait and see you got to get
through the evaluation process maybe you
love Derek brown or Jeff Okuda but if
you're the Lions I think you are very
interested in moving back to five six or
seven in this draft and trying to
accumulate more draft picks
especially the dolphins dolphins have
three picks in round one they set the
table for this moment that they might
have to trade up much like the Eagles
did much like the Jets did when they
traded up get their franchise
quarterbacks they've been ready for this
moment
so if they have to pull the trigger and
use one of those late first round picks
if you got to move 18 or you got to move
27 to get your quarterback from fine do
it you got to do it and will we see
someone replicate with the Jets did
remember how unorthodox that trade was
Matt was where they jumped from six to
three well before the draft it will we
see someone put themselves in the
drivers seat again where they sit there
the Jets knew the Giants were taking say
Quan Barkley at two now those teams will
do their investigative work to know that
the Washington Redskins are taking chase
Young at to where they need to get to
three with the Detroit Lions to cement
themselves in the taking to a and if you
do that trade now maybe you get a little
bit of a discount instead of waiting for
a bidding war on draft night yeah now
how the ripple effect of this is huge
obviously but we've also seen a lot of
decisions over the weekend as far as
underclassmen we're really waiting okay
okay the tide is coming we're waiting
for guys to declare and the wave came
chase Young declared Jeff Okuda declared
Jerry Judy Jedrek Will's Xavier McKinney
we heard Nick
save and reference other guys who had
declared Andrew Thomas JK Dobbins
deandre Swift a lot of players that we
have projected as first rounders we're
getting that point where we know what
they're doing there aren't many guys out
there that we're waiting you know for a
decision Isiah Simmons but Clemson still
playing the CD lamb has declared what so
we're not waiting for many big players
anymore Henry rug's is one that we
expect an announcement very very soon on
the Connor it this this class is
solidifying now and I still stand by the
fact that it's not a great draft class
in terms of how many top end players
there are but as the class fills out the
depth is starting to look really really
good it really is because and once again
this trickle this trickle effect it has
there's gonna be that you know the top
three offensive lineman really seemed
penciled in jerry judy CD lamb everybody
loves them you know people are gonna
love aja panetta there's a there is
enough talent in the top half of this
draft when you have burrow when you have
to a when you have a team that might
take herbert in that top half where you
know in those top 15 16 we just did it
for the dallas cowboys at 17 where they
each got players that you know or we're
gonna do it for the dallas cowboys today
at 17 where you know they're each gonna
get talented players you don't want to
give it away yet but you look at it
right now
this changes the dynamic of the draft
because this is such a huge piece at the
top yeah it absolutely is and knowing
you know I know some small house state
fans got their hopes up because chase
young said something like I'm not
thinking about the NFL Draft yet it was
right before a playoff game
he was definitely thinking about it he
knew what he was gonna do so we shall
Jonathan Taylor also declares for the
draft so a lot of the big names are in
one other big name has made a decision
and that is Jalen hurts former Alabama
and Oklahoma quarterback he has
committed to play in the 2020 Senior
Bowl this is the right decision for
Jalen hurts who threw all the
improvement that we saw this year and
there was a lot of it he needs to show
his ability as a thrower I've always
felt like he was such a tight thrower he
has this stiff rigid motion getting to
see him for a week in Mobile Alabama is
going to be huge for his draft stock
they don't answer a lot of questions of
is this a guy who is he
still add a three-player like everyone
thought when he got to Oklahoma or did
what he did this year and the potential
that he has to continue improving as a
thrower is that gonna help him enough to
drive him up boards and with the Senior
Bowl I this would be my tenth one Connor
you've been to a bunch of them Ella's
been a bunch of them
the thing with Jalen hurts you're not
gonna get to show off your ability as a
runner here and I think in some ways
that could not be a huge benefit to him
but you want to prove that you can get
it done as a thrower there's no better
platform for him to answer that question
step one of the off season for the
Dallas Cowboys was hire a head coach
they have done that Mike McCarthy new
head coach of the Dallas Cowboys but the
job's not done this is a team with 26
free agents including the starting
quarterback in dak Prescott starting
wide receiver Amari Cooper and a
starting defensive back at Byron Jones
not to mention a ton of other role
players that are very important to this
team now projected salary cap space is
84 million dollars which sounds like a
lot until you remember Rick gotta pay
Dec gotta pay Amar'e and then you got to
plug in holes of those 26 free agents
that you're losing it's a team that is
not loaded with draft capital they have
six selections before compensatory
selections which probably not gonna get
very many high picks at least the
projections I've seen so Conor with the
Dallas Cowboys
you got your coach you know what your
drafting for now you got to go fill
these holes but first and foremost you
have to sign dak Prescott you just hired
Mike McCarthy a guy who has won a Super
Bowl with Aaron Rodgers we've talked a
lot about what he brings to the table
but if you don't have dak Prescott it
really doesn't matter the market value
on dak I don't know that he's gonna hit
35 million a year but he's gonna be
somewhere between 30 and 35 million
dollars a year would be it would be my
guess on a five-year deal that's about
where the estimations that I've seen put
him at right now yeah so the guy you get
done is dak Prescott that's the one you
got to get done I know a lot of people
have said well you you sign one of a
Mario dak and then you franchise tag the
other and I understand the thinking with
that but Dax your quarterback he had a
fantastic season I think he's going to
be really good
under Mike McCarthy some of the staff is
gonna stay there that it's already
worked really well with him so like you
said Matt you're keeping dak in that
range probably around 35 million dollars
per year and then I would put the
franchise tag on Amari Cooper which the
estimated 2020 franchise tag for
wide-receivers is about eighteen point
five million if you do the transition
tag it's a little under sixteen million
dollars a year so I think you probably
slapped the franchise tag on a Mari
Cooper if you could find a deal he's 25
years old so if you can find a long-term
deal probably the guaranteed money runs
in three to four year range for someone
like that then you get that done but I
feel much more comfortable you know
putting the band-aid on Amar'e then Dec
I think you don't let it get to that
point with your quarterback you don't
risk your quarterback missing any of the
offseason you want him in the building
therefore OTAs minicamp
the start of training camp the most
important thing for the Cowboys is to
get this one done and of course there
has to be an odd man out of all these
free agents I think Byron Jones is that
guy I think a 27 year old defensive back
is probably the guy because you can't
pay everyone and I the fact that dak
came into this year is a lame duck is
amazing to me I don't know any other
quarterback who'd be like you know what
I know I don't have a deal for next year
if I get hurt I'm at big trouble well
I'm gonna go play and I feel like he'll
be rewarded for that I'm sure there were
promises made that will take care of you
don't worry about it you're not going
anywhere so I think he's gonna be okay
like you said someone has to go that's
probably Byron Jones and they have a lot
of young guys who are free agents you
know Malik Malik Collins a free agent
there in Thompson's fridge Anthony
Brown's a free agent so Jeff eath not a
young guy but someone who's been a
pretty important role player for them
tavon Austin's a free agent Robert Quinn
Randall Cobb a lot of guys who hulls
you're hearing these names right you're
like who cares about Randall Cobb but
that is a it's a roster spot at least
that you have to fill and I think that's
where you headed to this with okay after
we get DAC and Amari locked up we still
have other holes to fill and this is a
team that they've been very aggressive
in the past with three agency with the
draft where they're gonna be aggressive
about going out trying to fill these
holes but with six selections right now
it might be tough
- and you know we can look at the rise
of Michael gallop and say like okay they
feel pretty good about where they're
going at wide receiver
obviously at linebacker Shaun Lisa free
agent they're in good shape with Jalen
Smith and Layton Vander - as long as
Layton is healthy but there's gonna be
holes that this team has to fill Connor
we look at a mock draft we both did one
they have six selections they will be
picking number 17 overall I listed their
biggest needs and there are a lot of
them but I listed their biggest needs
and we'll see what happens before agency
D end D lined corner safety
you could put tight end on that list
very very easily I do think they'll need
to add another running back at some
point whether that's free agency or in
the draft just to have better depth
there but at 17 overall we went in
different directions I went with Grant
Delpit safety from LSU and there might
be some skepticism will he actually be
available at this spot I think he will
be we have seen safeties fall in the
last four to five drafts every year
Jamal Adams was not supposed to be at
six
Derwin James sure as hell wasn't
supposed to be a 17 no megha Fitzpatrick
fell in the draft safeties go later than
we expect you can rank a safety in the
top 5 chances are they're not gonna be
drafted there it's just not what the NFL
does they do not value that position
enough grant Delp it's 2019 season
wasn't that good maybe he was playing
hurt maybe he was protecting himself I
think we saw times where he would turn
it on and you may get flashes of a
player that he was in 2018 where he was
amazing so it's a little bit of a gamble
here and I think that's where you have
to have good information good sources to
talk to LSU and say what was up with the
guy it is he is he's still a little hurt
is he shaking the rust off or is he
playing scared or did he become a diva
like what are the reasons for him to
take a step back this year if you get
satisfied answers to that question I
think Grant Delpit is exactly what they
need
team em up with Xavier woods Darian
Thompson probably gonna be gone afraid
to see Jeff Heath I think has to be gone
afraid to see you got a huge need of
strong safety on this defense and he's a
guy that can make plays it's so many
different levels of the football field
we've seen him play in the box we've
seen him come down he'll make tackles
for a loss he's a really good Blitzer I
think he could run with tight ends very
easily he's been asked to sit back there
and play whether it's single high cover
two
do a lot of different things we talked
with Jacob Hester who's down there and
closer with that LSU team than anyone
and they said listen he hasn't been
given the freedom to run around and make
plays as much as he did when he was an
underclassmen so that takes away from
the box score production a little bit
I still like Grant Delpit a lot and I
love that fit with the Dallas Cowboys
just to take a little different look at
the approach here in round one I went
what Cole commits the tight end at a
Notre Dame I think they need a really
big bodied seem target red zone target
here for exact Prescott we don't know
what's gonna happen with the mario
cooper they should find a way to bring
him back
Mikel Gallup has been great but if you
get a young promising tight end that can
you know you never want to compare
anyone to a guy like Witten but a guy
with the play style like Witten as a
pass catcher where he's just bigger than
everyone else on the field reliable
hands soft hands he'll go up and win the
football I love what commit can do at a
Notre Dame and just think he's a
seamless fit in this Dallas offense and
well worthy of a top 20 overall
selection yeah I think so as well Kokomo
is my number one tight end and I if
you're like there hasn't been any buzz
about this guy we talked about it on the
Friday show he declared for the draft
after saying he was going back to Notre
Dame to play baseball so a lot like Kyle
Emery last year where we've been told
all season don't worry about this guy
he's gonna play baseball well then he
changes his mind and yeah we go again
rush a little bit to evaluate in round
two I went to the defensive line I feel
like this is an area where Dallas has
invested draft picks talking about Malik
Collins is a free agent he was a third
round pick Tristan Hill was a
second-round pick but we're not seeing
the production from those guys to match
that position and the coaches that bang
the table for Tristan Hill might not be
there anymore so this feels like a
direction where they could change I want
with Neville Gallimore defensive lineman
from Oklahoma and I do think that as we
expand and start talking about guys
outside of the top 32 everyone's gonna
really fall in love with Neville Callum
or we'll see him at the Senior Bowl his
first step quickness is really really
good for a 6-3 during a 20 pound guy he
can shoot through the line I actually
thought he was the best defensive
lineman in the big 12 this past year
which I know that's a low bar but still
the best D lineman in the big 12 he
wrecked everyone that they played and
has all the tools
redshirt senior he's been there he's
experienced he
I think he can get on the field right
away instead of guys like a Malik
Collins or Tristan Hill where he just
really felt like there were more
developmental pieces that were drafted
on promise I think with Gallimore he can
get on the field for you right away and
don't forget Michael Bennett also for
agent so he's gonna be gone too
that is undoubtedly an area where they
need another piece I think you know when
you look at Hill it was kind of a
disappointing rookie year there's no way
around it flashes at times but overall
they need a little bit more punch up
front like you said they're gonna be
losing a couple players so I totally get
that pick now you address safety in
round one I did not so I need to go back
down there in round two and I'm going
with Ashton Davis from Cal I think
somebody with range elite athleticism
he's a track kind of guy he could jump
through the gym good ball skills good
recognition and pass coverage
I think Davis is somebody you asked to
play he can play so many different roles
in the secondary I think he can really
even line up at corner whether it's in
the slot once again whether it's running
the seam with tight ends I think Dallas
can use more cover players like we said
we think they're gonna lose Byron Jones
and free agency and Davis is somebody
that you know it's hard to replace a guy
like Byron Jones but with his
athleticism how late he started playing
football there's still a ceiling there
for Davis to grow and be just a seamless
kind of fit into this defense you know
how much I love Ashton Davis we talk
about a long time he's special I'm a
little upset because I want him for my
49ers at free safety but I understand oh
you gotta they don't have a second-round
pick so you got to take them up the
board here round three it's pick 82 I'm
gonna go corner here we talk about Byron
Jones is a free agent and you know
honestly like we haven't seen great play
from the Dallas corners you remember a
couple years ago they drafted a woozy a
and Jordan Lewis in the second and third
round in the 2017 draft really that both
those dudes would become their starting
corners and play at a higher level than
the half
if Byron Jones leaves you have a pretty
big need at corner so that's where I'm
gonna go with camera dancer from
Mississippi State a underclassmen who
declared there were times I watched him
this year it's like man I'm really like
his length I like his instincts he moves
well other times I watched him and he
just got torched so I don't want to sell
Cowboys fans the false hope that this is
a late third or middle third-round pick
that's gonna come in and play right away
he's gonna be a superstar there's some
development needs done here but I think
Dan slurs shows enough flashes in round
three that I would feel pretty good
betting on his future the other player I
almost put here was Bryce hull from
Virginia but again we've talked about
him before he didn't have great speed
and then he broke his tibia and fibia in
mid-october so it sounds like he's not
gonna be ready to play anytime soon yeah
and you know it's fun when we do these
mock drafts I become guilty of this too
you try to get five to seven starters
all in once anyway yeah this is a Pro
Bowl Pro from day one sometimes it's
okay to take a developmental guy on
round three round four and he might not
see the field till the end of the year
he needs a year to develop because
sometimes those guys pan out for the
long haul so round three and I Matt you
said it before I think this guy is gonna
climb and cement himself into the top
sixty but he just has gotten no buzz
right now that's Justin mad at bouquet
from Texas A&M speaking of that
defensive line that we're trying to
patch up this is a player that the film
is really good honestly it's really good
and I know Texas A&M had some stinkers
this year because they play the most
insane schedule and all of college
football I've ever seen it's like
they're playing a top five team in the
country every other week but when you
look at Matt a bouquet I just think that
he could do a lot of things well he
really can he's disruptive he can stop
the run and I don't I'm saying this now
I'm putting him in round three because
this is kind of where that January
projection is but I think this is a
player that if you want him and feel
free to disagree with me Matt you'll
need to use a second rounder on him when
all said and done no I actually agree
with you I have him ranked right there
in in that range
I really like him he was someone I was a
little bit late on in the process he
when he declared I was like okay I've
seen him play because of how many other
people we've watched text is saying in
play but I had to go back and do some
work on him so I like his game a lot I
think he might even go a little bit
earlier than you have him going here to
the cowboy 282 round four this is where
I'm gonna address that edge rusher spot
because they like said Robert Quinn's a
free agent they have a great player in
tank Lord's but they need more of a pass
rushing I think that's gonna be one of
the things that when Mike McCarthy gets
there he's got to realize this team
needs a lot on defense and so I'm gonna
go conclude cream from Notre Dame
Notre Dame has two really good pass
rushers click cream and Julia no para
Julia no guara is a great athlete he's
flashy he's fast he can bend but his
production mmm like no I'm always that
great what clique cream it's like he's
not the opposite yeah absolutely his
production is amazing and he uses his
hands and he can play with power but
he's not gonna wow you his three cones
not gonna be great his short shuttles
probably not be great but watch him put
on a helmet shoulder pads and go after
offensive tackles and I think people
will be very very excited with what he
brings to the table and again my theme
with this outside of camera Dantzler I
wanted guys who could come in and play
right now because this team is trying to
win a Super Bowl occlude cream can come
into play right now and make an impact
like people love comparisons
I was watching Trey Hendricks and
yesterday I was like man that is a
little man like what he and click cream
they're so similar and how well they
could play the run they could stack up
against tackles and Trey interest-rate
with someone I remember liking on film
and then he didn't have a great combine
it was like oh I don't know if this guy
can play on the edge in the NFL then
he'll go to a team where they're just
gonna ask him to play basically there's
a strong side a defensive end and he's
had a really good career so far so I
look at click cream and say you could be
that type of guy
yeah Notre Dame's funny that their
situation reminds me of a couple years
remember when Georgia had both Leonard
Floyd and Jordan Jenkins yes and it was
like man Leonard could be this 15th sack
kind of guy but it is not there yet
it's just not and then you look at
Jordan and you're like Jordans gonna be
like seven sacks every year very very
high highly graded outrun defender
rock-solid great teammate leader and
that's exactly how it's gone Jordan
Jenkins just gets better each year for
the Jets and Leonard Floyd the the
ceiling was never met and you look at
these two guys from Notre Dame and a lot
of people are gonna love that film from
Kareem and they're gonna sit there and
say man he's a rock-solid football
player and that's the route I went here
in round four but Jabari Zuniga from
Florida listen do I think is in digas
this elite athlete and is the production
always off the charts it's really not
but I think he's a rock-solid football
player and I think for Dallas right now
you're seeing a trend with us in these
middle rounds you're building depth
you're building reliability in the front
seven
and in the backend of the defense you're
finding ways to fill these holes that
are losing in free agency and these guys
might not be always the flashiest
players available in the draft but
they're the ones that get you through
that homestretch that get you deep in
the playoffs when everyone else is
banged up round five I did what you did
in round one
I will Harrison Bryant I knit from FAU
and maybe not the best scheme fit for
what Dallas had been doing previously
but I think his speed and if Mike
McCarthy truly took his year away from
football to evaluate where offenses are
going and how the you know we're seeing
this innovation I think he would like
someone like a Harrison Bryant who's 65
225
he was my pick for the Mackay Award
winner for the best height in a college
football he is an excellent athlete but
he is a flex player he's light he's lean
he's not gonna be this ass-kicker that
you put next to your right tackle and he
George kills everybody in the run game
but if you are committed to motion to
getting guys in space then I think
Harrison Bryant could be a really good
fit we haven't seen that role and Mike
McCarthy's offense previously I
completely admit that but I'm hoping
that we see him innovate and try to
catch up with what the rest of the
league's do and you look at our guys
like Foster Murrow
Dawson knocks the roles that they're
playing in in the NFL and the impact
that they've had as rookies ain't
Harrison Bryant as a day three pick
could come in and have a pretty big
impact yeah not bad when you have a
Macky Award on the resume as well listen
that alone should get you drafted round
five for me I went with somebody that I
wouldn't be honest with you still
surprising declare it I guess things
were you know that disarray during his
time at Florida State but Sanford
Samuels the cornerback from Florida
State this is a long lean kind of corner
a former top recruit some had a mess of
four-star some Adam as a five-star so
we're talking very very high-end ability
and I think what Stanford Samuels he's
somebody where you know you went with
this option in round three and Cam
Cameron Dantzler you're getting a
developmental corner you like the traits
you like what they are it's that ball of
clay that you feel like you can mold but
you don't think they're gonna take the
field from day one next year I think a
lot of teams are gonna look at Samuels
like that and say listen this guy left
early he was not in a good situation in
college the film is probably a little
bit up
down but we believe that we can get the
most out of him and the reason this guy
was a high-profile recruit at the time
so I think for Dallas once again here's
more of a you know adept developmental
kind of picking around five with Samuels
yeah Samuels is an enigma beat for me he
could go to a team that's like you are
six to 185 pounds you're gonna play and
cover two and we're gonna take advantage
of your size he goes somewhere where
it's like you're gonna have to use your
instincts and technique he's gonna
struggle a little bit so I think I went
out a matter with him my last pick in
this trap they don't have a round six
picks around seven I'm gonna give them
Tyler Johnson and I know there's been a
lot of conversation on Twitter about the
fact that I'm very low on Tyler Johnson
I have put my money where my mouth is I
bet a Viking not a bit I told a
Minnesota fan that if he's a first-round
pick I'll donate $1000 to the charity of
your choice
fees a day to pick I'll donate $500 to
charity of your choice
fees a day three pick I just get to be
right and I'm okay with that that's
worth it to me Tyler Johnson is an
intriguing player aurelius he is tough
he makes contested catches he's been
wildly productive over the last two
years I do not think that he is fast
enough to separate from NFL defenses
there have been concerns told to me by a
number of area scouts about work ethic
about coach ability and this is a player
who was not invited to the Senior Bowl
which will usually tell you a lot I mean
they're taking ten receivers to the
Senior Bowl you're not in that list so
add in all the underclassmen we're
seeing the receivers position and then
ten senior wide receivers and you stack
below those guys in this class for the
most part so where are you gonna get
drafted I love that Tyler Johnson has
fans but I believe that he will be a
late pick and for Dallas that could be a
home run if he can get if he could prove
that his route running is good enough to
separate then he does some very nice
things with contested catches but you
know like like many players before him
if you can't run in the NFL wide
receiver you got to be pretty damn good
at something else
and for me with Tyler Johnson I'm just
not sure what that is yeah I listen sign
me up for Tyler Johnson in round seven I
like that and like you said Matt you
know it's unfit there's been a lot of
back and forth on this and I think there
are fans in Minnesota that want to
support their player there are fans or
analysts of college
that love what he's done on the field
and I think is it fun on this podcast
that we get to do those things we get to
be fans and we get to cover college
football of course but in your lens in
January your lens is how our NFL team's
going to value this guy yeah and I think
that's very important to note here with
Tyler Johnson that listen if you're
saying he's going day three he's
probably going day three and I think the
Senior Bowl thing is very interesting as
well you know that's something we'll
have to talk to Jim nagging about he's
very open about invites and non invites
and it's something we'll keep an eye on
but I think you know in round seven
sure why not and for me round seven I
went with the sure why not wide receiver
in a little bit of a different mold
because this guy can run he ran a 4-3
eight in high school it's just the
problems are everywhere else Jeff Thomas
out of Miami you know doesn't play in
the bowl game to Claire's early an array
of off the field kind of issues really
reliability is the big one with this guy
now the Dallas Cowboys they're a team
that's not afraid to take a guy like
this on day three I think and Thomas
once again he's a great athlete we've
seen flashes of brilliance from him at
times in college I know he can play
football this feels a little similar to
Antonio Callaway to me where he's
probably gonna he's probably gonna have
his own pro day or Miami pro day if that
happens and they're gonna time him in
the four threes I mean that's brilliant
stuff he's gonna catch the ball he's
gonna show he could play specialist he
could do a lot of different things but
that character situation is is rough
around the edges and is gonna drop him
to the point where he could not get he
could possibly go undrafted I agree I
agree and you watch him playing like man
this guy can he could play a little bit
but then you talk to teams a lot like
with Tyler Johnson and you'll get you
talk to 16 teams and they'll say we
haven't undrafted on him it doesn't take
one something we say all the time all
right Dallas Cowboys are fixed we went
heavy on defense and then added some
pass catchers I would have liked to have
had about three more picks to pick some
of the other tips on here but that's
what you got to do that's why you have
84 million dollars at cap space to
figure it out alright that is our show
Congrats to Tula on a hell of a career
can't wait to die
more in this draft process through where
he ends up Connor the Wednesday show
we're gonna break it down with a mock
draft so no mock draft Monday
you're gonna mock draft Wednesday which
doesn't no alliteration but it's a
little longer that's it yeah the juice
will be worth the squeeze we promised
Mara Wednesday Excel entitlement quote
right there's actually love it when I
can quote Dave got them on me and my
computer folks getting it done the
mellow we'll be back with this Friday
morning
thank you all for hanging out a long
show today but we think it was worth it
we'll talk to y'all real soon